es kam ich schon zuvor so oft im
leidigen breaks it prozess der tag der
entscheidung sollte es werden die
entscheidung über den austritt aus der
eu über boris johnsons neuen deal doch
dann dieser änderungsantrag der mit 322
zu 306 stimmen angenommen wurde
sie handelten sex der sogenannten edwin
zusatz besagt dass die entscheidung über
das abkommen erst dann rechtskräftig
werden kann
nachdem alle dafür notwendigen
gesetzesänderungen ratifiziert sind die
regierung entschied daraufhin die
abstimmung auf nächste woche zu
verschieben
per gesetz ist der premierminister
allerdings dazu verpflichtet in brüssel
eine verschiebung des austritts datums
zu beantragen
johnstons reaktion darauf ich wäre keine
verlängerung mit der eu verhandeln und
das gesetz verpflichtet mich auch nicht
dazu
[Musik]
es herrscht also erst einmal weiter
unklarheit der brief muss bis heute
mitternacht abgeschickt werden in der
debatte zuvor hatte die opposition ihre
ablehnung des johnson deals deutlich
gemacht ich bin mit der frustration und
ermüdung die das land und dieses
parlament empfinden bewusst aber wir
können einfach nicht für einen deal
stimmen sogar noch schlimmer ist als der
denn dieses haus in der einmal abgelehnt
hat widerstand gegen das abkommen zeigte
sich heute auch auf den straßen londons
zehntausende forderten erneut ein
zweites referendum
doch ob es dazu kommt ist nach dem
heutigen tag genauso wahrscheinlich oder
unwahrscheinlich wie ein brett ohne
abkommen oder mit das chaos geht
schlicht weiter diana zimmermann in
london wieder eine neue wendung also wie
könnte es denn jetzt weiter gehen
eine neue wendung ja aber irgendwie auch
das alte nämlich tiefes misstrauen in
diesem parlament gegenüber dem
premierminister es ist die achte
abstimmung die er hier verliert und er
hat als reaktion die wir gerade gehört
haben gesagt er sei per gesetz nicht
gezwungen einen eine verlängerung des
brh exit prozesses zu verhandeln
allerdings gibt es den brief mit dem er
um den aufschub bitte schon und zwar
wird er das im namen des parlamentes tun
so sieht es momentan aus bis heute abend
mitternacht muss dieser brief
abgeschickt sein schickte er ihn nicht
ab dann befindet er sich im konflikt mit
dem gesetz jetzt ist der stichtag für
den wechsel der 31 oktober die zeit wird
also knapp kann das noch klappen
boris johnson hat angekündigt dass er
nächste woche die gesetzgebung rund um
den deal auf den weg bringen möchte
montag oder dienstag theoretisch ist es
möglich diese gesamten gesetze die an
diesem deal hängen noch vor dem 31
durch zu bekommen und eventuell sagt die
eu ja wir genehmigen eine verlängerung
wenn ihr vorher fertig seid könnt ihr
auch vorher austreten das haben sie bei
theresa may
auch schon mal gemacht also theoretisch
ist das möglich praktisch allerdings
wird es bei diesem sehr gespalten
parlament sehr schwierig sein diese
ganzen gesetze mit einer mehrheit zu
verabschieden
vielen dank für die erklärung im
unruhigen london diana zimmermann
und damit weiter nach brüssel zu stefan
leifert london nimmt also offenbar
wieder eine auszeit wie reagiert die eu
ja mit seiner mischung aus verwirrung
und gelassenheit jean claude juncker hat
vor ein paar minuten erklären lassen
dass er jetzt darauf wartet dass die
britische regierung aus london ein
signal sendet und erklärt was sie denn
jetzt zu tun gedenkt es gibt die anders
man hat es gerade gesagt im grunde ja
nur zwei möglichkeiten entweder boris
johnson bleibt dabei dass er keinen
brief mit der bitte um verlängerung nach
brüssel schreibt dann besteht hier auf
eu-seite auch kein handlungsbedarf dann
geht man davon aus dass der deal weiter
steht und es irgendwie möglich ist vor
dem 31 10
die gesetzgebung in london abzuschließen
sollte er einen brief nach brüssel
schicken mit einer bitte um verlängerung
dann könnte die eu seite darüber relativ
schnell entscheiden morgen früh treffen
sich hier die eu-botschafter und die eu
seite hat auch immer deutlich gemacht
dass eine verlängerung an ihr nicht
scheitern würde solange es nur eine
technische verlängerung ist also ein
bisschen mehr zeit um den
gesetzgebungsprozess in london
abzuschließen also man wartet jetzt erst
einmal ab was london denn überhaupt zu
tun gedenkt vielen tagen stefan der
fahrt nach brüssel